daybook TV lineup continues now with Ron
Kovic the author celebrated the
paperback release of his book born on
the 4th of July this is from the 2005
los angeles times festival of books held
in april it's a little over an hour ends
the introduction of his new of the new
edition of his book it does end on a
very positive note maybe one will read
that after but I always want to say
something
I first met Ron Kovic in 1971 in the
cemetery near here at UCLA we've both
been at an anti-war demonstration and
everyone left night fell and there we
were sitting with all the crosses that
you've probably driven past maybe
occasionally visited and I remember at
that time thinking you know I'd been in
to Vietnam I'd written about the war so
it wasn't quite the abstraction that it
might have been but still I'm sitting
there talking to Ron it got to be dark
and it just was so such a chilling
reminder of the consequences of our
policy decisions in our mistakes and I
talked to Ron that night and then Ron
has always come to my class at USC we've
stayed close friends and when I heard
that this new edition of his book came
out the first edition as you know it
became a movie with Tom Cruise nominated
for eight Academy Awards Ron himself was
nominated for Academy Award for the
writing of it with Oliver Stone won two
Academy Awards he won a Golden Globe
Award
and the book itself received an
incredible it was published in 1976
received incredible front page review in
the New York Times Time on Sunday and
every writers dream on Monday got
another favorable not just favorable
glowing review as what Johnny temple
Johnny temple is I'll introduce in a
minute but anyways just a great moment
that was 1977 and then the movie came
out in 89 and so it's been a long thing
and the book had been in print for about
30 years a classic like All Quiet on the
Western Front or Johnny's got his gun or
what have you and then suddenly it was
out of print for a few months there and
Johnny temple who is the publisher of
akashic books who is a reformed
rock-and-roller no I shouldn't say that
he still tours he's going to be in
Moscow in a few months he was in Egypt
and so forth but Johnny temple is 37
years old and of a different generation
decided that this is a book that had to
stay in print and he decided to publish
it you want to say something about that
sure I had the opportunity the first
time I met Ron was a little more than a
year ago maybe about a year and a half
ago when my company had reissued a
collection of short stories by the great
world war ii writer james jones and we
had also published a novel by James
Jones's daughter Kelly Jones and Ron
knew Kelly and Kelly asked Ron if for a
reading she was doing in Los Angeles if
if Ron would be willing to read a story
from her father's book and they did so
it was an incredible experience except
for the near riot that happened during
the reading but we had the opportunity
beforehand of having dinner with Ron and
we hit it off immediately and I was a
little shocked to find out in this day
and age that mcgraw-hill had let the
book go out of print which is you know
even even the bean counters you know
we would have a motivation to keep this
book in print it's taught widely in
universities and I can't imagine a book
that's more relevant right now and so
Ron got the rights back and supported
akashic books you know a struggling
independent and it's been an incredible
experience it's a huge honor for me I
also had the honor of publishing a book
that Bob co-wrote the five biggest lies
Bush told us about Iraq and and it was
it was a further honor that for for our
new edition of born on the 4th of July
that Ron wrote this incredibly powerful
introduction which discusses both his
experience writing the book as well as
tying what's going on now in Iraq to his
own experiences in Vietnam and what he
is seeing
and in addition we added a postscript to
the book and and it's just I'm you know
very happy to be here today it was
what's that PostScript was and the
PostScript was and perhaps it can be it
can be read today but it was a actually
maybe maybe the PostScript should just
be read because it sort of speaks for
itself ok I'll let you do that but let
me just set this up a little bit since
this is a book festival in honor of
books I want Ron to talk a little bit
about what this book meant to him
because it he's described it very
beautifully in the book there is also
going to be a book signing
nearby is that right and it's a
beautiful handsome addition with this
new introduction but I want to just read
the poem that Ron wrote up preceded the
original edition I am the living death
the Memorial Day on wheels
I am your Yankee Doodle Dandy you're
John Wayne come home your fourth of July
firecracker exploding in the grave and I
think we needed to be reminded of the
consequences not that's the end of the
discussion but the consequences of war
and what they represent that it doesn't
go away the - Jessica Lynch's of this
wall will still have their wounds if
they are fortunate to live 20 30 years
from now and in your book you mentioned
that you didn't think you'd live very
much longer I know it's been a struggle
continuously and I know that the book
writing a book gave you a new lease on
life at that point so maybe you could
just begin by describing them
Thank You Bob it's a thank you everyone
thank you everyone for coming it thank
you Bob Thank You Johnny it's I think
it's very important that we're gathered
here today it's a it's an honor to be
with all of you I'm very grateful to be
with you and I think it was what was it
30 years ago almost 30 years ago 30
years ago in Santa Monica California in
one month three weeks in two days on a
$42 manual typewriter that I had bought
at a Sears & Roebuck in Santa Monica I
wrote born on the 4th of July it was a
very humble beginning the war was still
going on back then and it would not be
over with until the spring and it would
be and not be over with for many of us
who came home from that war as is the
case with those young men and women who
are now coming home from Iraq it would
not be over with us for many many
decades to come I I did not think that I
would live to be 30 years old when I was
writing born on the 4th of July in that
apartment on that $42.00 manual
typewriter in the fall of 1974 I felt as
if I was I felt as if I was writing my
last will and testament I really didn't
think that I was going to live that long
and I wanted to leave something for all
of you something behind I didn't I
didn't even know if it would ever even
become a book as I began to write those
pages every night those chapters every
night I used to think I remember
thinking one morning because I work all
night long until dawn I don't know how
many of you like the late nights but the
late nights are very quiet and they're
very peaceful and everybody's sleeping
and it's a little less intimidate
and I I would ride all night until dawn
and I would found the keys with two
fingers so hard that my fingers would
hurt and it was timeless and I would
would write as the Sun came up I would
finish writing and then I'd go and I'd
let transfer out of my wheelchair onto a
mattress on the floor and I remember on
one particular morning thinking to
myself I was having heart palpitations I
was having nightmares I was having
anxiety attacks during this period and I
thought to myself if I die in my sleep
if I die in my sleep I hope that someone
comes into this apartment and I hope
that they find the pages that I've
written so far which would always be
neatly stacked next to the that $42.00
typewriter on the kitchen table and I
hope that they realized that I that I
wasn't a victim that I was struggling
that I was trying to rise above what had
happened to me that I was trying to rise
above the injustice of that war and
that's what I was feeling in the fall of
1974 no Ron went on well began then and
went on to play a very active role in
peace movement and he's done that around
the war in Iraq but I just want to read
as an addition maybe you could read it
johnny is in addition because our war
heroes don't always turn out to be the
way the government would like them to be
and Ryan had gone back for a second tour
of duty in half - he volunteered the
first time but there's a letter do you
have the booklet yeah why don't you read
it then this is the letter that was sent
to Ron's parents I guess it was about a
week after general Lewis Walt was kind
enough and compassionate enough to send
a letter to my mother and father I was
still in the intensive
in Danang vietnam and i had sent a
letter to my mother and father telling
them that i had been paralyzed in the
war and it was a letter that i also sent
to general walt and he ended up sending
this letter he responds by sending this
letter to my mother and father i think
it was a week or two after I was wounded
and I'm still in the intensive care ward
in Danang at the time johnny reads
better than I do dear mr. and mrs.
Kovach February 14th 1968 dear mr. and
mrs. Kovach just prior to your son Ron's
departure from Vietnam he very kindly
sent me a copy of the letter in which he
informed you of his wounds in his peril
ed paralytic condition that letter was
the most inspirational one I have ever
received from any of our Marines in
Vietnam and I received quite a few I
have written to Ron and my next thought
was to write to you to express my
sympathy as I reread the letter as I
reread the letter however it came to me
that while I quite naturally feel
sympathy for Ron and for you condolence
is not what I want to express but rather
gratitude I'm extremely grateful that
our country is composed of people like
you who can raise so fine a son Ron's
faith in God his dedication to his
country and his strength of character
reflect the highest credit on the
upbringing you gave him despite the fact
that he is partially paralyzed I know
that his spirit in his faith will
continue to flourish and that his future
contribution toward a free and peaceful
world
will be equally as worthy if not more so
as that which he so gallantly
contributed in Vietnam you have my
deepest respect and admiration as does
Ron he is the type of young man of which
Americans and free men everywhere can be
proud sincerely LW Walt Lieutenant
General US Marine Corps oh and
he's also the old man we can be proud of
and maybe you could talk something about
your literary inspirations and you
mentioned being in a bookstore when
you're started you told my class the
other night would you like to know about
my inspirations let's talk about my
inspiration we all are inspired by
writers and authors and let me just sit
here and dream for a moment before all
of you and think back think back all
those years and I was in the hops draw
University Bookstore on Long Island I
had just gotten out of the Bronx VA and
I was trying to go to school I had the
opportunity to go to Hofstra University
and I was a poor student in high school
I never did that well in high school I I
didn't like school
and I struggled in high school but here
I had the opportunity after being
wounded and after the I think was about
11 or 12 months at the Bronx VA to go to
a university and a good university a
fine one Hofstra University so I went
and I found myself I think was the first
week or two when you're supposed to pick
up your books for the first time this
was all new to me and you know I had
just come from the hospital imagine this
I had just come from the wounded I just
come from being around some of some of
the most severely wounded of the war
paraplegics and quadriplegics the young
man across from me had was paralyzed
from the neck down in the hospital and
and Here I am in the bookstore among all
of these wonderful young vibrant
students it was just night and day and
and compared to only the year before
when I was in the intensive care ward in
Danang Vietnam
battling fighting for my life in and out
of morphine and then suddenly I was in
this bookstore and I was waiting online
and I was looking at some of the books
and I picked up a copy of Erich Maria
Remarque s' you know this book all Quiet
on the Western Front and I remember
picking up the book and I had I believe
I had never seen it before
and I remember opening up to the first
page of all Quiet on the Western Front
I remember reading on the front of the
book international bestseller and that
so it made an impression on me that this
book had affected people deeply and
widely people had been profoundly
affected by this book around the world
and I I read that first page and I think
I read a little bit of the second page
and I remember thinking I would like to
do that someday
I would like to write a book like that
someday
that was one of the first thoughts I had
I remember that and I remember being in
California a couple of what was it a
year or two later I had become involved
with the Veterans Against the War I
think at the time I was still with a
group called the California veterans
movement and I hadn't I had not yet
joined the Vietnam Veterans Against the
War which I was later to do I was
invited to a gathering in Hollywood it
was a party it was a party for a movie
called Johnny got his gun and the movie
was based on a book written by Dalton
Trumbo Dalton Trumbo one of the
Hollywood ten is that correctly one of
the Hollywood ten and I I had read that
book before I went to the party
I had read Johnny got his gun someone
had given it to me and it affected me
deeply
I remember the character in Johnny got
his gun was Joe Bonham go bottom
how many of you have read Johnny got his
gun that's quite a few people in the
audience a very powerful book
beautifully written very simple very
profound I believe it was written
correct me if I'm wrong I believe it was
written sometime around 1939 is that
right about 1939 and I remember the
character we know what happened in
Johnny got his gun and we know this
young man was wounded savagely severely
in World War two and he attempts to
communicate and it when he finally is
able to communicate out of his
horrendous wound he wants to be shown
around the world he wants people to see
what war is really like and he thinks of
himself as a living death a living death
now this affected me a great deal I
identified with this this fictional
character this fictional character I
identified with Dalton Trumbo character
and Johnny got his gun and I had the
honor that night at the gathering the
party in Hollywood of meeting with
Dalton Trumbo he was celebrating the
release of Johnny got his gun which I
don't think it it lasted that long
the film version of the book but I got
to meet him and I shook his hand and I
and I I was so excited to meet the
author of this book which had moved me
so deeply so profoundly which had
touched my soul which I was able to
identify with so strongly where this
this book which all of a sudden even
though it was fictional all of a sudden
I wasn't alone I wasn't alone someone
someone somehow someway through this
book through their words someone
understood me someone understood what I
and the others around
me who had been wounded as I had been
wounded what we we had gone through what
we were still going through and so I I
thanked him and I told him how
profoundly this book had had moved me
and he signed his name on the back of my
wheelchair a wheelchair I no longer have
I've long since discarded or lost I'd
say you know I saved the back of that
with a screwdriver I took the backing
off that chair I actually took the
backing off that chair and I saved it I
saved it and you know what he wrote on
the back was interesting he not only
signed Dalton Trumbo but he wrote
nothing more as to be said I think he
wrote nothing more is to be said it's
it's only to be done to be done and I
thought about that a lot what did that
mean did that mean that that everything
against war everything about the horror
the terrible nature of war the
senselessness of war the futility of war
had already been written about and now
there was nothing to do but action
activism speaking out I still am not
sure exactly what he meant when he wrote
nothing more as to be said it's it's
only to be done but nonetheless I I was
proud of that that autograph and and and
what he had written and I carried it
with me like many things for as long as
I could it's a miracle that I have
anything from all those years those
years were so intense and they were so
wild and emotional and it was such a
such a ferocious roller coaster ride for
me and for so many of us who came home
from that war it was such a such a a
rough ride a difficult time emotionally
physically coming back returning to this
beautiful country that is ours that we
all live in and I
at the honor when the movie came out
about the time the movie came out I
received a phone call from New York and
I found out that Dalton Trumbo 'he's
book was being reissued that he had
written an introduction while he was
still alive to actually he had written
an introduction during the Vietnam War
during that period and I had read that
introduction to that edition of his book
and they they needed a new introduction
they asked me if I would write the
introduction to the new edition in 19
when was it 1990 yeah almost 20 years
after I had read his book and I I agreed
and I did have the honor of writing the
introduction of the of that edition of
Johnny got his gun so things came full
circle and that book affected me deeply
and profoundly in the writing aboard on
the fourth of July we asked you in terms
of the images we have one image you said
you were in Vietnam veterans against the
Warriors one image put out about you
know and Kerry tack on the Kerry
campaign and the other is sort of the
John Wayne image of a patriotic glowing
America and and those two images have
kind of gone through your own life as
they did in the poem that I read before
do want to comment on that at all or
they specifically well the whole that
this we talked about movie imagery and
the vision of heroism and so forth and
and it's played with all the time well
let me make more specific when the movie
version of this I know you spent a lot
of time what was it about 10 years
trying to get the movie made well why
don't you tell the story of Oliver Stone
we after all was a movie maker but he
had been at war he'd gone himself on two
tours he'd been wounded and how this
movie came to be made out of the book
and how it was different than say the
John Wayne image
well the first point did that you made
talk about that first point because I
find it very interesting because I was
born on the 4th of July I did grow up
with Mattie Mattel submachine guns and I
was inspired by John Wayne tears did
come to my eyes when he climbed Mount
Suribachi at the end of the movie I did
watch Audie Murphy on top of the flaming
tank in Ted was a talent pack Helen back
and I I was deeply patriotic and I feel
I'm deeply patriotic today before all of
you but we'll talk about that as we go
on but I was deeply patriotic and I was
inspired as many of you in this room
today and many in our country were
inspired by John F Kennedy when John and
I put that in the beginning of the book
that's not what your country can do for
you but ask what you can do for your
country
what can I do for my country what can I
contribute to my country so our intent
as a generation as young men John Kerry
myself and and all of us all of us that
went through that war and all of us that
was sent to that war in many ways there
was a purity there was a love of country
that was sincere and genuine you may
want to call it naive but it was real
for us it was genuine and we were ready
to risk we were ready to sacrifice I was
ready to sacrifice I volunteered to go
back to Vietnam a second time and I
think that there's something very
beautiful and tragic at the same time
about that we see it in the young men
and women now serving in Iraq
what is sad and what is tragic is that
there is as it was in my commitment to
this country and to that particular
foreign policy decision I think I think
that there is this is a very precious
thing that we're talking about lives
we're talking about mothers and fathers
we're talking about a commitment to go
to war and so few of us as Americans as
citizens of this country I think so few
of us really understand what it means to
send young men and women off to war and
and the the it is not just something
that that that is over with quickly it
is something that sometimes lasts for
many decades people are shattered people
are shocked people are stunned people
may never be the same again we saw it
with our generation we saw it with our
brothers with our fellow veterans with
the men who went to that war we saw many
of them become alcoholics
we saw many of them go to prison we saw
many of them end up on the streets of
this country homeless we saw many of
them suffer from psychological stress
post-traumatic stress disorder they
still wander the streets of this country
today do we really understand when we
make that decision when we sew when we
sew I'm trying to think of the word in
such a Cavalier fashion often we say
where that 90% that that supports this
this decision to go to war for instance
with Iraq or in the early beginnings
with the war in Vietnam
because I understand and there are
brothers of mine and fellow Vietnam
veterans of mine are in this audience
right now who know full well what that
decision means and when a government
deceives when a government misleads when
a government does not give the whole
truth because we must give the whole
truth because we the young men and women
of this country we're willing to give
our whole lives we're willing to give
everything that is precious to ourselves
to life itself and and and if our
government deceives and of our
government misleads this this this is
this is something that is very tragic
very awful so you see there's a
vulnerability here there's a
vulnerability we're very young and we
don't really know and I'm talking about
Bob when I was younger and I was so
patriotic and I had read the sergeant
Rock comic books and I had played with
the guns and I had grown up in a culture
which which which respected this flag
and and and yet yet as I moved toward
that that that that war there's a
vulnerability here these are young lives
these this is over 58,000 young men
these are two million Vietnamese we're
talking about life and we're talking
about a governments that that that
sometimes mislead and and so we need to
be extremely careful we need to be aware
I was both the the the patriot and and I
was the John Wayne marine and I'm proud
to say I also became committed to peace
and to non-violence inspired by Martin
Luther King
inspired by the peace movement proud to
be marching against that war I had the
great honor and opportunity to be a part
of history and to be a part of many
aspects of that history and to see it
very close up with my own eyes
well that answers it a little bit yeah
I'm going to lighten the mood now I want
you to tell a Hollywood story it's a
story told my class the other night
about the making of a movie and the
whole idea of mass culture I mean it
seemed pretty incredible you got the
book published but did very well as I
say got these incredible reviews
everywhere but then to enter that next
realm to make it a mass movie why do you
tell that story and don't leave out the
part about grabbing Oliver's lapels
we're having his oh you want me to tell
that story that I told the other night
again let go we're at us USC can I say
that here you could say use can I can I
say that can I say USC at UCLA I grabbed
Oliver Stone's lapels is she shared
because do you want to hear this story
tell also it's a wonderful story every
day it's a great story no it's a great
story you know what's the story about
not giving up on your dreams not giving
up so let me just preface by saying the
first time the first time Al Pacino
wanted to portray my life I've never
been so lucky Al Pacino wanted to be
wanted to portray my life and this was
the first step after the movie had come
out I had gone into New York City I had
met with Martin Bregman who produced Dog
Day Afternoon as Serpico and this was
all happening to me this was all such a
big thing for me but I I stepped ahead I
moved ahead with it I wanted to reach
more and more people with the message
that I had tried to write in the book
and anyway to make a long story short
that
film got within about what was it a week
or so before principal photography and I
fell apart and oh they had hired a
screenwriter in the beginning of that
and he had tried to write a screenplay
and it didn't work out and they were
looking for another screenwriter Oliver
Stone had just come back from London
from writing Midnight Express and which
was later to win he was later to win his
first Golden Globe in his first Academy
Award that was his first big
breakthrough and Oliver had been walking
on the streets in New York one afternoon
and he had run into a friend I think
that he had gone to college with he had
been in school together with and who
happened to be working with Martin
Bregman and I believe that he he he
mentioned the that that Bregman was
looking for a screenwriter and would
would would he would Oliver be
interested and or woody at least come
over to the office so he did and one
thing led to another and on July 3rd
1977 Oliver Stone came out to the west
coast and we met at the sidewalk cafe in
Venice for the very first time that's
where we met for the first time the
sidewalk cafe in Venice and we were - he
had written platoon by then but no one
wanted to do it no one was interested in
he was very frustrated he was trying to
get platoon we were two angry young men
back from the war and we were we would
determined to get our stories out and I
remember we had lunch at the cafe and
you know I remember saying to Oliver
that day you know that's a really
interesting name Oliver Stone
honestly I said this to him I said
that's a really interesting name Oliver
Stone I said you know it sounds like it
sounds like a name that's going to be
famous some day I said sounds like
you're gonna win an Academy Award or
something I sincerely I said that too I
mean I was quite quite interesting so
that that film fell through that first
attempt with Al Pacino fell through and
and then then civil several caught a few
years passed and almost what was it
almost 10 years but stone had made a
commitment to you yeah oh yeah when the
film absolutely when the film fell
through the first time we were in an
elevator and Oliver in New York and
Oliver said to me if I have a
breakthrough if I ever make it if I ever
become a director because you see back
then no one even knew who he was and he
said if I breakthrough if I become a
director I'll come back for you Ronny
and I'll I'll make born on the 4th of
July
I'll direct born on the 4th of July so
he made a promise to me back in the late
70s that if he ever made it if he ever
broke through he would come back he
would make born on the 4th of July
and I he never forgot that promise and I
remember that promise as the years went
by and then suddenly there was Salvador
and then this phenomenal film platoon
which was a phenomenon extraordinary
film extraordinary anti-war film
extraordinary film about the Vietnam War
and it moved the American people and it
moved people around the world deeply I
went to the opening door yeah it is his
story and the character actually the
character Charlie Sheen who plays I
believe Chris and platoon I believe
represented Oliver and in the movie
I went to the opening night to the
opening of the or the screening of a
platoon and I remember you know I
congratulated Oliver afterwards and we
were walking together and I remember the
promise I thought of the promise that he
had that he had made if I but I couldn't
bring it up I could not say to him I
didn't want to say to him do you
remember that promise you made to me in
that elevator in New York long ago that
if you ever broke through you'd make
born on the 4th of July
I wanted him I wanted him to come to me
and say it if he was going to say it
because that was his decision and I you
know as time went by I I remember
listening on the radio I think was on
the radio one day I heard a story where
he was going to do a follow-up to
platoon and it was going to be called I
believe a second life I believe that was
the title but a second life and I I I
was I felt I felt sad at first I felt
well he's not going to he's not going to
do it he's not going to make born on the
fourth of July and and then I thought to
myself well you know at least we tried
at least we tried and at least one of us
broke through and he was able to break
through at least he got his story out in
a big way he was able to break through
and so time went by and one morning as I
was telling the story at USC the other
night one morning I I got up I was
living in Redondo Beach at the time in a
rented house and I got up and there was
a phone call from an agent I believe in
Los Angeles telling me someone that I
knew I didn't even have an agent at the
time but an agent telling me that Oliver
Stone was going to be calling me from
New York he was finishing up the movie
Wall Street in New York and he was going
to be calling me from New York and he
wanted to take out an option on born on
the 4th of July he wanted to try to make
book and it was it was it was
I received a call about an hour later
and I felt very calm and he started
talking on the phone and he was warning
me to not get as excited as I got last
time the time before he said there were
no guarantees these things can fall
apart at any time and I promised him
that I would try not to I get too
carried away and too excited I got off
the phone and I felt very quiet and
peaceful inside and I had a feeling that
that no matter what happened no matter
what we we were to come up against that
this time it was going to be made and to
go back to the grabbing the lapels story
I was asked to give an award to Oliver
Stone one night I can't remember exactly
what it was for
might have been for the Liberty Hill
foundation but it was one of I was
honored to give him on a number of
occasions to to actually give the give
the speech and and present the award it
was a great honor and I at this
particular gathering we were at a table
just before the event was about to begin
and he was across from me and a
nonchalant fashion he said nonchalantly
he said look we're not going to I
decided we're not going to make the
movie oh by the way I had already gone
all the way to New York I'd gone out to
Massapequa my hometown with Oliver we
had spent an entire day together and you
know we so we had we had done that and
it looked like the film was going to be
made and then all of a sudden I'm
sitting at this table and he says he
said he said to me look I'm not going to
make the movie and and and I I didn't
know what to say
and so I found myself pushing my
wheelchair up toward him and grabbing
his shirt
and I thought to myself if you don't let
him know right now how you really feel
that you're going to lose this movie
you're never going to have this
opportunity and it really did mean a
great deal to me I said you've got to
let him know right now and I in about
five minutes I'm supposed to go up and
give him an award I'm supposed to give
him this award in five minutes
so I I push my wheelchair and I put the
brakes on the side and I go right up to
him and believe me I absolutely am a
practitioner of non-violence and peace
and I've made that commitment but I
grabbed his shirt and I pulled that
shirt I think I almost pulled the
buttons off his shirt you know and I
pulled him toward me and I told him I
can't remember the exact words I said
that day but it was very passionate and
it was a little too loud because people
were looking around at the table at the
man who was going to was supposed to
give Oliver Stone the award who was who
was grabbing a shirt and and looking at
him intensely in the eyes and shaking
him and telling him they had no idea
what I was telling him but I was telling
him why he could not walk away from this
why we had to make this movie so there
was a moment of indecision there was a
moment of hesitation which it was only
human but I responded as was as any
desperate person would as any desperate
person would
[Applause]
let me just let me just conclude by say
I went up and I still in the back of my
mind his words what he had said to me
and I you know I let go and he sat down
and that was fine and I went up and they
then I went out on the stage and I had
to present the award to him I had to be
very dignified so I went out there and I
and I gave I I thought to myself still
with feeling I had to convince him more
I thought well what Bob told me don't
give a speech you know don't don't give
a suit but I said to on that particular
day I said I've you know what this and
this was a I think I don't I can't
remember if this was a black-tie event
or it was people were well dressed and
they were very comfortable and I decided
to give a fiery speech so that he would
remember who I was so that he would know
why he wanted to make the movie about me
in the first place so I ended up giving
the speech which which which which you
know which fired up the audience quite a
bit and you know the audience I I think
we could have we could have marched out
of that ballroom and taken over a
building somewhere but but but what we
didn't but but once I guess make a long
story short I got my car my hand control
car I drove back to Redondo Beach that
night and I remember feeling very
peaceful inside thinking to myself I've
done everything that I can possibly do
what more could I have done to impress
upon him how important this was to me
what more could I have done with all the
passion that I had and I slept well that
night I think one of the few nights that
I've slept well since I came home for
the war but I slept well that night and
I woke up the next morning and about 11
o'clock now as I said to the student
see the night at about 11 o'clock in the
morning the phone rang and who was
calling me tell me who was calling me
Oliver Stone Oliver Stone was calling me
and he had changed his mind he had
decided to put the movie back on track
he had decided we are going to not even
begrudgingly he had decided we're you
know we're going to continue to try
we're going to work a little bit hard
and we're going to see if we can make
that movie so believe me if you ever see
your dreams slipping away and if you
ever feel that someone's made a promise
and is is wavering on that promise and
that's only human but if that ever
occurs in your life grab for the shirt
and get ready to give a speech
sort of a hell of an example here all
over LA tomorrow writers from the
writers going grabbing shirts III do
want to just go a little further with
this because so much that happens in
Hollywood that's good or bed is by
accident or the effort of individuals
that you wouldn't expect we had a panel
this morning where they talked about the
blacklist and conspiracies of how movies
got made and we hear about liberal
Hollywood and so forth but actually this
movie got made because Tom Cruise was
willing to play in it and I was going to
ask you basically two questions his
willingness to play and he was a big
star that he didn't need this movie and
whether he got it right whether a movie
can capture the book whether your story
was told fairly because it's an
incredible movie not only Tom Cruise but
we met with let me tell you who we met
with before we met with Tom Cruise we
met with first we met with the very
talented actor Charlie Sheen and we had
Oliver Charlie
Oliver myself we had dinner in Santa
Monica and for one reason or another
that didn't work out and then we met
with Sean Penn at Oliver Stone's house
when he was living in Santa Monica at
the time and the three of us met with
Sean Penn and I drove up from Redondo
Beach and I think Sean Penn had just
gotten out of jail and he he needed to
be he needed someone to drive him over
because I not sure but I believe that he
didn't have his license at the time I'm
not sure but I think that was the case
but I was surprised he was just such a
gentleman such a very gentle person such
a very kind and quiet very quiet person
and we met with him and we talked for
quite a while that that didn't work out
for one reason or another that didn't
work out
and I felt you know each time we met
with an actor I felt that it was
slipping away again and I felt at the
time I was ready I would have worked
with personally myself I would have been
willing to work with just about any any
one of them just to get the movie made
just to make it just to ensure that we
could begin just to begin because it's
so hard just to begin and and so then
there was a period of quite a few months
I can't remember exactly then in what
was it 19
[Music]
let's see 1986 87 88 I think it was in
the B get a time not exactly sure but
Oliver Stone called me and told me that
he would like to bring Tom Cruise down
to a meet with me in Redondo Beach and
of course I agreed I I felt I wasn't
sure about Tom at first because I had
seen him in risky business
I hadn't seen oh I love risky business I
thought it was a wonderful film I
enjoyed it I enjoyed watching I thought
he was wonderful it was beautiful in
that film and but but I didn't know if I
didn't know if he had the depth to
portray what I had my experiences what I
had been through and at the same time I
want to share with you that I thought
well if even if he even if he does this
and even if it doesn't reach a great
number of people I had no idea what it
would do even if it's not a great film
at least I will be able to get my story
out to more people more people will be
able to to to understand what I and what
others went through Oliver Stone brought
him over to my house
and I remember being immediately you
know he ran down the driveway Tom ran
down the driveway and the first thing he
did was he hugged me I think he shouted
my name he said Kovac Kovac and he
hugged me and he and he just about
lifted me had a book wheelchair just
about lifted me out of the wheelchair
just swept me up in the chair and it was
and I hugged him as hard as I could big
bear hug and I remember a few minutes
later Oliver Stone and Tom Cruise
sitting on my bed in my bedroom watching
on my TV home old home movies of me when
I was a boy when I was still on my feet
hitting a home run running around the
bases my Cub Scout uniform and my Boy
Scout uniform saluting proudly and so we
watched home movies of me as a boy and
then we went to the kitchen I just
remember some bits and pieces of that
day and Tom was sitting on the sink and
Oliver was sitting on a chair and I was
how impressed I was at Tom's
intelligence his ability to articulate
the story my story
he understood I feel like he understood
he empathized and he also understood
that we had gotten so close to making
the movie within just a few days of
principal photography back in the late
70s with Al Pacino and that it had
fallen through and that had been
heartbreaking for both Oliver Stone and
myself and he understood what that meant
to us and he made it clear to me in the
kitchen that day that he was not going
to let us down that we were going to
make this movie and I believed him that
day I believed him Oliver Stone left
early that day I remember and Tom and I
walked around the neighborhood I
remember we took a walk together and we
talked about different things but I was
to spend
once after that initial meeting we
decided to go ahead in the end as I
think back to it it was really Oliver
Stone's final decision but of course I
was a part of it I was a part and he
allowed me to be a part of so much of
this film I'm very grateful for that but
Tom and I began to spend time together
we began to go out in wheelchairs
you know I remember him coming over to
Redondo Beach to my house once in a car
and I remember saying to there was
someone in my house a friend of mine and
I said well he Tom Cruise pulled up my
friend said and I was waiting in the
house and I was excited that tom was
coming or we were going to work in
wheelchairs together and he pulled up
and I said well you know it was a minute
or two or three minutes had passed and I
thought you know just take someone that
long to get out of a car and come to the
front door and he said well he's tried
he he's trying to transfer into into a
wheelchair you know he tried to open up
that wheelchair and he's trying to
transfer into the wheelchair I mean you
should explain what I mean we take this
for granted but when I've been out with
Ron to go to dinner or something is
before he got his new car which took 35
years or something you had to put a
board down yet to get on the board move
over the whole complexity of it yeah
you're transferring was you know
transferring was was a challenge was a
physical challenge I enjoyed it for many
years until it began to tear apart my
shoulders but anyway Tom we ended up in
the back yard and we ended up working
together and I was very impressed that
he chose to visit me for the first time
with his wheelchair and in that manner
and we were working out in the back yard
and I was trying to teach Tom how to do
wheelies in the backyard
and I remember popping I'm in a lecture
in an electric wheelchair now and I was
in a manual wheelchair up until you know
37 years up and I've only been in the
electric wheel
in the last couple of months but I was
still able to do wheelies this is this
is a bit too heavy to do wheelies now
but I'm instructing Tom in the backyard
and how to do wheelies well I just want
to give an example of Tom's great
courage
tom is Tom's just-just-just wants to
jump into everything you know he's not
afraid of anything and very courageous
and so he he threw himself into this and
so he's trying to Tom's trying to do
wheelie and and all of a sudden he goes
over backwards and there were these red
bricks in the in the backyard and he
went over backwards and his head bounced
like a ball you know just when he went
backwards and he went backwards and his
head bounced and and he I thought it
would have knocked him out I mean I was
but Tom came up smiling you know smiling
and laughing he just Tom just started
laughing you know and I just I knew we
had a real winner there you know again
Ron we just uh we're going to end just
in a few minutes but I just uh I told
you not to give speeches bro this little
game going but I I do want to ask you a
final question you know let's say having
observed you and how like I called
around the other day because I was
incredibly moved by the introduction I
really urge everyone to buy this book
give it to friends but I tell Ron I had
the book and I read the introduction and
I you know just flipped me out and so I
said he said well I haven't seen it yet
so I said well I'll come down there and
give you a copy so Ratana beach and he
said oh no he said I'm just getting
started
and then he described what he had to do
to get going in the morning and it's not
kidding around you know it's a real
routine it's really difficult and and so
you know we talked earlier about it you
talked about in the book you know not
giving in to despair not becoming angry
develop you know keeping and developing
your sense of humor you know and the
sort of positive and in the movie you're
really bitter you rip out the lines yell
and you tell me and I've seen it in our
connection how you've become you know
much more positive about life and so
forth and is actually
might want to read the last paragraph of
the book or the introductory I think
it's important to realize that let me
share this with you today that you know
we all not just myself all of us in this
room and all of us we all experienced
tragedy those of us that choose to keep
on living we experience loss and tragedy
and grief and we all will and we all
will be knocked down and have to pick
ourselves up and get back up again
and I I am so grateful to be here and to
be alive I am so so thankful to be able
to have found meaning in my life my
commitment to peace and non-violence my
commitment to trying to make this world
a better place and my commitment to just
each day trying to be a good and decent
human being just trying to be a good
neighbor trying to be kind
I really enjoyed writing the
introduction it meant a lot to me
because for years I felt I had written
the poem and I am the living death your
Memorial Day on wheels I am the living
death you Memorial Dan wheels and I had
written from my heart and I had I had
written about some of the worst of what
I had seen what I experienced I wanted
that war to end I didn't want any I
didn't want more young men at that time
to have to come home like me in a
wheelchair for the rest of their lives
enough had died already on both sides
and that was I had not even begun to
heal I had not even begun to come back
from that war and so many of us who came
back from that war so many of us
struggled we
able to find our lives again after that
war we struggle to be able to love again
after that war to be able to feel again
after that war we struggle through
nightmares and we struggle through
anxiety attacks and we struggle through
a myriad of barriers and difficulties
but I wanted to write this introduction
I wanted people to know that I was still
here and I wanted them to know that this
world for me is a beautiful place and
that that that so much has been given
back to me that my life has been a
blessing in disguise
that that tragedies can be turned into
triumph they can be overcome and this is
important too
with all that anger and bitterness which
is understandable with all that rage
which is which is understandable for the
loss for the suffering for the grief
there's there's the beauty of finding
life again of realizing regardless of
what happened that this is still life is
worth living that this is a beautiful
world so at the end do you have a moment
let me read the end of this
acknowledgment it's and Johnny I want to
thank you as my publisher and my editor
for allowing me to write a 3400 word
introduction you know I just want to say
Johnny's been patient saying up Johnny's
what's the name of the group shiny
grills against boys so well known I know
a lot of my students really impressed
that I know this guy and he happened to
make a deal one day or his group didn't
they got some money and instead of
blowing it on what you can blow money on
he decided to go into the publishing
business and I think he's got a hell of
a line a book
thank you and Johnny I just want Johnny
to know it was such a pleasure working
with him he's a wonderful wonderful
wonderful human being and it I just want
you to know was an honor putting this
new addition together with you and I
think it's beautiful and I'm grateful
thank you this is a let me read this
this this year this is the the end of
the the the introduction and and this is
something I I've wanted to share for a
long time I guess and let's see if I can
read this quickly I'm no longer the 28
year old man six years returned from the
war in Vietnam who sat behind that
typewriter in Santa Monica in the fall
of 1974 I am nearly 60 now my hair and
beard are almost completely white the
nightmares and anxiety attacks have all
but disappeared but I still do not sleep
well at night I toss and turn an
increasing physical pain but I remain
very positive and optimistic I still am
determined to rise above all of this I
know my pain and the horrors of my past
will always be with me
but perhaps not with the same force and
fury of those early years after the war
I have learned to forgive my enemies and
forgive myself it has been very
difficult to heal from the war while
living in America and I have often
dreamed of moving to neutral ground
another country yet I have somehow made
a certain peace even with a nation that
so often still seems to believe in war
and the use of violence as a solution to
its problems there has been a reckoning
a renewal the scar will always be there
a living reminder of that war
but it has also become something
beautiful now something of faith and
hope and love I've been given the
opportunity to move through that dark
night of the soul to a new Shore to gain
an understanding and knowledge an
entirely different vision I now believe
I have suffered for a reason and in many
ways I have found that reason in my
commitment to peace and non-violence my
life has been a blessing in disguise
even with the pain and great difficulty
that my physical disability continues to
bring it is a blessing to be able to
speak on behalf of peace and to be able
to reach such a great number of people I
saw firsthand what our government's
terrible policy had wrought I endured I
survived and understood the one gift I
was given in that war was an awakening I
became a messenger a living symbol an
example a man who learned that love and
forgiveness are more powerful than
hatred who has learned to embrace all
men and women as my brothers and sisters
no one will ever be my enemy no matter
how hard they tried to frighten and
intimidate me no government will ever
teach me to hate another human being I
have been given the task of lighting a
lantern ringing a bell shouting from the
highest rooftops warning the American
people and citizens everywhere of the
deep immorality and utter wrongness of
this approach to solving our problems
pleading pleading for an alternative to
this chaos and madness this insanity and
brutality we must change course I truly
feel that this beautiful world this
beautiful world has given me back so
much more than it is taken from me so
many others that
Ainu are gone and gone way too young I
am grateful to be alive after all these
years and all that I've been through I
am thankful for everyday life is so
precious thank you
[Applause]